well it's even like when we talk about
cheating like if the guy does it it's
always we demonize him but if the girl
does it the first question is always why
like why what made her cheat why did she
cheat no I would I would say I would
always ask why did the guy cheat I
always I don't think that's do you think
do you think that's common when you see
it on when you see it on say tick tock
when they tell cheating stories it's
always that if you look at any cheating
story on Tick Tock if it's a girl
telling it the story of how she cheated
like they'll always say oh well why did
she cheat
what yeah but for the men it's like you
know if I say he cheated because he
hasn't slept his wife hasn't slept with
him in three years they still make him
out to be the bad guy yeah